the torpedo didn't fail it must have
malfunctioned i disarmed it we let the
flagship of the free navy escape because
of me if philip hurts more people than
it's not about philip it's about us i
can't be the one who kills your son
this is kamina drama
and this message is for the traitor
the coward
marco inaros
you hunted me and mine and still we are
here unbent unbroken unbowed and you
you are nothing
hey guys pete here i have another short
expanse video for you today a preview of
episode 4 where i'll look at these two
teasers that they put out and the x-ray
episode with bobby and amos that i
didn't get a chance to talk about in my
episode 3 recap i did talk about that in
more detail in the live stream i just
did a couple of hours ago and i do think
that our second attempt turned out a lot
better than the first one so i would
recommend that you check that out if you
didn't watch live because i think that
we got into some really interesting
stuff that i just can't get into when
i'm breaking down the episode as far as
spoilers i'm going to talk about the
episode description i'm going to talk
about these teasers and everything that
happened to get us to this point if any
of that sounds like spoilers to you then
this is your chance to leave and with
that out of the way let's get into it
in this third installment of the x-ray
bonus episodes you can't really go wrong
putting amos and bobby in a room
together and have them carry on they
make another reference to the doctrine
of one ship which is an ongoing thing in
each of these episodes here amos says
the doctrine of one ship encompasses
both tension and resolution with bobby
adding with no favor to either conflict
and acceptance unified into something
greater these two are cleaning out the
cargo hole doing some work on the ship
and they continue with this back and
forth that they've got going where
they're sort of testing each other
they're messing with each other of
course and they both get in some great
barbs and it escalates to a challenge
since holden wouldn't like it if they
actually fought bobby suggests a simple
game the first one who hits the deck
loses and that person has to clean up
the rest by themselves amos assesses the
situation he realizes that bobby is a
worthy adversary and so he says let's go
over the rules to distract her and makes
his move when she isn't ready yet it's a
great idea but it doesn't actually work
she's able to counter she puts him into
a sleeper hold and she starts choking
him out i really enjoyed her saying it's
almost over it's almost nappy time and
from his perspective we see that he is
starting to go out he's almost there as
he's struggling though he's eventually
able to get out his hand terminal he
uses that to set off an alarm that
causes her to let go while she's
surprised and not paying attention he's
able to get a hold of her slam her to
the floor and wins the contest in the
end they laugh and it's clear they have
a mutual respect and appreciation for
each other and amos keeps things going
keeping things playful by offering to
help her up and then he pulls his hand
away before he actually does that there
were a lot of great lines here great
chemistry between these two a lot of fun
all the way around and i should mention
that the actor who plays amos west
chatham has his first writing credit on
this so congratulations to him on that
one of the things that popped out to me
in all of the exchanges between these
characters was how they have a lot of
subtle callbacks to the early seasons in
their conversations here after bobby
says remember when the earth had a blue
sky amos responds remember when mars had
two moons and that pulls up her very
first scene on the rossi where she came
at the crew pissed off after she saw
that someone had to face the martian
flag of course it was amos who actually
did that and it made for an awkward
conversation between them as they were
first getting to know each other so
they've come a long way and you gotta
love watching them work together
episode four is titled readout and the
description reads holden finds himself
at odds with his crew when a
controversial decision is uncovered on
series avasarala struggles to contain an
escalating humanitarian crisis drummer's
growing faction stage a daring raid with
dire stakes philip demoted to repair
skip duty makes an unexpected discovery
and besides the abasaralis stuff this is
mostly what we see in these promo clips
in the first teaser for episode 4 we
hear holden come clean about disarming
the torpedo that was about to destroy
the pela there we see philip and another
crew member looking at it sticking
through the ship's hull and you can hear
the belters say it must have
malfunctioned so that's where it ended
up right there from what we get here
naomi doesn't sound pleased about her
life partner slash captain's decision
she says if we let the flagship of the
free navy go because of me if philip
hurts more people and at this point
holden interrupts to say it's not about
philip it's about us i can't be the one
who kills your son and the teaser ends
there there was a lot of speculation
about holden's motivations here because
it's hard to understand how he came to
the decision that he made and i guess
you at least get part of it right here
he doesn't want to be responsible for
phillips death it's the kind of answer
that brings up some new questions he'll
have to answer because that's not really
what you want to hear from the captain
of a ship that's on the front lines of a
war against the free navy that he can't
pull the trigger the second and final
teaser is all about drummer and i just
wanted to take a second to say that
these teasers the ones that they made
for twitter specifically in the squared
aspect ratio they've been fantastic for
three weeks in a row they do a really
good job of putting these ones together
in this one we see kamina drummer
declaring in a public message that marco
is a coward and a traitor she says you
hunted me in mine and still we are here
unbent unbroken unbowed and you
you are nothing beyond her just being
badass
a few other things jump out here first
as i said this is going out everywhere
we see that people everywhere are
watching it on video feeds she's not
just calling him out one to one she
could also be swaying other belters who
might be on the fence about the free
navy also in the beginning you can see
her ship approaching what looks like two
clusters of shipping containers tethered
together which makes for a striking
image and in her speech she almost uses
the house words of house martell from a
song of ice and fire when talking about
her family it's a little out of order
but if you were wondering where that
sounded familiar from that might be it
it seems safe to say that drummer is
going to be causing problems for the
free navy and marco in the next episode
and with the story of ceres and what's
happening there the new attack that just
happened and everything else with that
getting out to other people she may be
able to complicate things for him and i
can't wait to see how she goes about
that so i think that's a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought about the x-ray episode
what you thought about these two short
teasers they don't give us a lot but
they give us something so i'll keep
making these if you guys keep watching
them if you want to dig a little deeper
into what we thought about the last
episode do check out the live stream
that we did and try to come and join us
for the next one next week i'll be
posting about that ahead of time so look
back for that and check out my recap for
episode 4 after the episode airs please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon